thanks very thanks very much for joining
you Wednesday President Bush announced
plans to alter us space policy by
calling for a new man launch vehicle to
replace the space shuttle program and
outpost on the moon and eventual
exploration of Mars next ken Croswell
gives an overview of the red planet's
geography air and water discussing his
new book magnificent Mars this program
is 45 minutes hello I'm Wendy Sabin
Lasker and the director of the daytime
program here at the mcore Steinhardt
center of the 92nd Street Y the daytime
at the Steinhardt program is a new
initiative of the 92nd Street Y that's
offered here on the west side for adults
with flexible day time schedules and an
interest in leisure learning our
noontime lectures provide food for
thought on topics such as lifestyles and
life stages Science and Technology
literature and business history great
cuisines with demonstrations by some of
the city's most important and fun shifts
and of course science and current
affairs today's talk on our sound of
science series couldn't be more timely
as we fuel our fascination with the red
planet it's my pleasure to welcome dr.
ken Croswell he's an astronomer and
author of an extraordinary new book
called magnificent Mars it was recently
published by Free Press and Simon &
Schuster and ken is with us today to
talk about this book and fuel further
our fascination with that planet let me
tell you a little bit about what else he
has written ken
first of all earned his doctorate in
astronomy from Harvard University and
he's authored five other books including
the best-selling magnificent universe as
well as planet quest which explores the
discovery of new planets and other solar
systems and was named a New York Times
notable book of the year his other books
include the alchemy of the heavens
written about the milky way see the
Stars heralded as one of the simplest
most let's call it user-friendly
constellation guides
and the universe @midnight which
explores the latest developments in
cosmology and was named the best
astronomy book of the year by New
Scientist his newest book and the topic
of today's talk is magnificent Mars and
it is a magnificent book presenting the
planet in all its glory with stunning
images of Mars and its moons
we have copy of the book today and will
ask our astronomer and author to stay
with us and sign copies for anyone who'd
like to leave with it today so please
welcome and please hold your questions
till the end if you would and then we
invite you to go on up and ask whatever
is on your mind about magnificent Mars
please welcome Ken Krauss well thank you
thank you very much one day it's a
pleasure to be here speaking about Mars
and if we can have the room as dark as
is humanly possible that would be great
but of course we have to keep some
lights on it's a real pleasure to be
speaking about Mars because Mars is one
of the most interesting planets in the
solar system because like Earth it may
have given rise to life billions of
years ago but unlike the earth it still
preserves a record on its surface of the
ancient era when life was struggling to
rise on Earth and possibly on Mars
furthermore Mars will surely be the
first planet to welcome human settlers
think back 200 years ago in places like
Oregon and Washington were far off
little known lands to most Americans
well today places on Mars like Olympus
Mons and Valles Marineris are equally
little known to most people but two
hundred years from now they may seem as
familiar as Oregon and Washington
do today my goal with magnificent Mars
was to produce the most beautiful most
lavish most extravagant book ever
devoted to the Red Planet
nearly every image in the book is in
full color every image was digitally
reprocessed by Tony Hollis was an
outstanding astrophotographer with the
ambitious goal to make them look even
better than NASA's own official versions
every image you see on the screen during
this talk is in magnificent Mars and
every image is reproduced very large in
the book the book weighs nearly 5 pounds
well there's so much to say about the
planet Mars that I decided to organize
magnificent Mars and this talk around
the four elements earth air fire and
water in the earth chapter
talk about the geology of Mars and the
inner chapter I talk about the
atmosphere of Mars in the fire chapter I
talk about the volcanoes of Mars and in
the water chapter I talk about the
element that's crucial for life and
present evidence for Martian floods
rivers lakes maybe even an ocean to
begin though if I could have the first
slide I'd like to begin with an overview
of Mars things that every earthling
should know about our neighbor in space
but our fourth planet from the Sun and
the first thing you should know about it
is it is the fourth planet from the Sun
it's 50 percent farther away from from
the Sun that is the earth and therefore
it takes longer to go around the Sun a
year on Mars lasts 687 days
so if you're 60 years old you see only
32 birthdays on Mars and therefore
during your life receive fewer birthday
presents the solution to this problem I
have already implemented here on earth
and that is to accept birthday presents
any day of the year the day on Mars is
actually very similar to a day on earth
because both planets take about 24 hours
to spend and as you might imagine it's
cold on Mars the mean temperature on
Mars is 67 degrees Fahrenheit below zero
however the temperature does get up to
about 80 degrees above but as cold as
minus 195 Fahrenheit at its worst and
there are two reasons that Mars is so
cold one of them you probably already
know the other you may not be aware of
the one you know is that it is 50%
farther from the Sun than as the earth
and so it experiences weaker sunlight
the less obvious reason is because Mars
unlike Earth doesn't have much of a
greenhouse effect
contrary to the view of most Earthlings
even the earth is too far from the Sun
to be warm and it's only the presence of
small quantities of greenhouse gases
carbon dioxide and water vapor that
allow the earth to be as warm as it is
the earth ought to be an ice-covered
planet with a mean temperature of zero
degrees Fahrenheit but it's only the
presence of these greenhouse gases which
allow sunlight to penetrate to the
surface warm the surface but then when
that surface tries to radiate that
warmth into space those gases trap it
and as a result instead of being zero
degrees Fahrenheit the mean temperature
of the earth is 60 degrees Fahrenheit in
the case of Mars the atmosphere is
almost entirely carbon dioxide
so thin as thin as the Earth's
stratosphere that the greenhouse effect
there raises the temperature only 10
degrees Fahrenheit and Mars is a small
planet it's only half the diameter of
the earth therefore it has 1/4 surface
area but keep in mind that about 3/4 of
the earth is under water so the land
area Amara's actually equals the land
area on the earth and one of the themes
of Magnificent Mars is that Mars was
born too small many of its present
problems stemmed directly from its small
size and we've known why Mars was born
so small ever since 1755 when prescient
philosopher immanuel kant's identified
the culprit as the planet Jupiter
Jupiter's the most massive planet in the
solar system it's right next to Mars in
the solar system and when the solar
system was young
it's gravity stirred up the objects
trying to conglomerate into Mars and
stunted the red planet's growth so as a
result Mars became only one ninth as
massive as the earth nowadays we can do
computer simulations of developing solar
systems we can leave Jupiter out of the
equation altogether and when we do that
we find that the fourth planet from the
Sun actually grows into a much larger
world comparable in size to the earth
and then the final thing you should all
know about Mars is that it's got 2 moons
if yet have the very next slide you'll
see the larger of the two moons whose
name is Phobos which means fear an
appropriate companion to the God of War
and the next slide shows a closer view
of Phobos and the next slide shows a yet
closer view of Phobos the smaller moon
of Mars is called damos and you'll see
that in the next slide and then in the
next image you'll see something you've
probably never seen before it's a
topographic map of Phobos in which red
indicates high altitudes yellow
indicates medium altitudes and blue
indicates low altitudes and the thing
you'll notice most of all about these
moons is that they're not round that's
because they're so small large objects
like the song the earth the moon have so
much gravity that the gravity squeezes
them into spheres but the moons of Mars
are just a few miles across and they
don't have to be round and the next
image shows a topographic map of damos
and then in the next image you'll see
the elliptical shadow of Phobos falling
onto the Martian surface so that's the
basic overview of Mars I'd like to now
launch into the
part of the talk and talk about the four
elements of Mars earth air fire and
water as revealed by the latest
spacecraft missions such as the one
shown in the next slide the Odyssey
spacecraft which went into orbit in 2001
if I cover the next slide I'll start
with the very first element Earth
you know our basic goal in trying to
understand Mars is to piece together the
planets full life story from its birth
4.6 billion years ago up to the present
day and to see if at some point it got
warm enough and one enough to have life
in some ways this is actually easier to
do on Mars than on the earth because the
earth the same things that make the
earth such a wonderful place to live the
air we breathe the rain the life itself
also erode ancient rock so it's actually
very hard to find old rocks on the earth
the the earth is 4.6 billion years old
but the oldest rock we have from the
earth is 4.0 billion years old so the
first six hundred million years of Earth
history are completely missing from the
geological record but Mars has much
better preserved its ancient terrain the
first the the the forty percent of the
martian surface actually dates back to
the first 1 billion years of solar
system history and we already have a
rock from Mars that's older than any
rock known on the earth and I'd like to
now explain how we are able to deduce
the ages of different parts of Mars if
we could have next slide you'll see a
fairly smooth region of Mars we deduced
that this is a fairly young area because
it doesn't have it hasn't been around
long enough to suffer lots of impacts
from asteroids and comets and the next
slide shows a more heavily cratered
region and therefore an older region and
then the next slide shows a very heavily
cratered region one that probably dates
back to some four billion years ago now
a fundamental fact about Mars is that
the north part of Mars is very different
from the south part of Mars the north
part is fairly smooth and depressed the
south part of Mars is heavily cratered
and elevated and the next slide shows a
full map of all of Mars and on this map
and when I identify some key features
and then show you a topographic map of
the same scene in which these features
will stand out even more clearly in that
on this map North is up South is down
zero longitudes at center
around the northern part of this map
you'll see the plains the northern
plains of Mars which are fairly smooth
and they lie low three forests of Mars
drains into the northern plains in other
words if it were to rain all over Mars
3/4 of that water would flow into the
northern plains left of center you see
the farces volcanic plateau which
contains some of the great volcanoes of
Mars and in eastern Tharsis you see the
canyons of Valles Marineris and then
throughout the south of Mars you see the
cratered Highlands punctuated by two
giant impact basins helis on the right
and are gyre on the left then the next
slide shows a topographic map with the
same orientation North is up South is
down zero longitude at center again the
color scheme is as before red means high
altitudes yellow means medium altitudes
and blue means low altitudes and now you
see around the top of this map the
northern plains all colored blue
indicating a low altitude they're fairly
smooth again 3/4 of Mars drains into the
northern plains left-of-centre that red
region is the Tharsis volcanic plateau
and the white peaks in that red region
are volcanoes taller than Mount Everest
and in eastern Tharsis running through
that red you see narrow lines of green
and blue these are the great canyons of
Valles Marineris and then throughout the
south of Mars you see the cratered
Highlands punctuated by those two giant
impact basins helis which is the purple
scar on the right and our jar which is
the blue-green region on the Left nobody
knows why this north-south dichotomy
exists it's possible that long ago
several asteroids happen to smash into
the north part of Mars excavated
material and threw it south it's also
possible that Mars once had continental
drift and the continents happened to
drift southward I'd like to show the
next slide now which shows the a labeled
topographic map of the equatorial region
of Mars and again you see the dichotomy
blue toward the top yellow and orange
toward toward the bottom indicating
again that the north part of Mars is is
depressed relative to the south part and
the next slide shows the north polar
topographic map nearly all blue
indicating again a low elevation and the
next slide shows the south polar
topographic map mostly yellow and orange
in getting a high altitude the South
Pole Amara stands for miles higher
than the north pole on Mars so that's an
overview of the Martian surface I'd like
to now show images from the first three
spacecraft that have successfully landed
on Mars starting with the very first one
Viking one in 1976 you see rusty rocks
beneath the pink sky long ago ancient
people named Mars for the God of War
because the color the red color the
orange color reminded them of blood and
we now know that they were right that
the same two elements that colored blood
also colored the Martian soil blood
turns red when iron bearing hemoglobin
joins with oxygen Mars is red because
the same two elements iron and oxygen
joined to form rust in the Martian in
the Martian soil and the next image also
shows another image from Viking one
you'll notice the sand dune sculpted by
the wind
in the same year 1976 the Viking 2
lander landed much farther north at a
latitude of 48 degrees north latitude
same latitude as Seattle and the next
image shows the view from Viking 2 and
then in 1997 a Pathfinder spacecraft
landed and returned this wonderful
360-degree panorama shown in the very
next slide now you look at all the rocks
on the Martian surface you think what we
could learn about Mars if we could
somehow bring those rocks back to earth
well we've never actually done that but
we still actually have rocks right here
on earth from Mars because every now and
then Mars which lies right next to the
asteroid belt gets smashed into by an
asteroid and that asteroid kicks up
debris and some of that debris impacts
the earth and the next slide shows a
meteorite all the way from the planet
Mars and conveniently enough this cube
came with it so apparently the Martians
have already indicated who they support
for president this year the Martian
meteorites have told us a lot about Mars
in particular the composition reveals
that Mars was born hot and that the core
of Mars formed the iron core of Mars
formed within just thirteen million
years of the red planet's birth
collective move on with the next slide
to the second great element of Mars air
and talked about the Martian atmosphere
if I could have the next slide the
Martian atmosphere is important not only
for the phenomena that it supports but
also because it preserves clues that it
was once much thicker probably as thick
as the Earth's atmosphere and the reason
that's so very important is because
Mars had a substantial atmosphere in the
past it could have had a substantial
greenhouse effect and been a lot warmer
than it is today first though I want to
show you some wonderful atmospheric
images from the Pathfinder spacecraft
you've probably never seen the Sun
setting on Mars well the next slide
shows you the Sun setting on Mars a
Martian sunset as viewed from the
Pathfinder spacecraft and the next slide
shows the same scene just a couple
minutes later the sky Aymara stays
bright for up to two hours after sunset
because there's so much dust in the air
and it rises so high it it bounces the
base sunlight to the ground the next
slide shows some pink clouds in the
Martian sky and the following slide
shows some blue clouds in the Martian
sky now the Martian atmosphere is
actually very thin less than 1% as thick
as the Earth's atmosphere as thin as the
Earth's stratosphere nonetheless it's
able to do things the next slide shows
some light colored dust streaks through
this dark region of Mars is dust
deposited downwind of craters on Mars
and the next slide you'll remember the
Viking one scene that showed those sand
dunes well here you see a crater from
above and the southern section is
covered by dark sand dunes and every now
and then so much dust gets thrown into
the air and more on Mars that a dust
storm envelops the entire planet the
next slide shows two images from the
Hubble Space Telescope the first was
taken in June of 2001 you see the
planet's surface and the second was
taken three months later when a dust
storm was covering the entire surface so
these two images are actually of exactly
the same hemisphere of Mars but in the
second one you barely see anything
because the planet is shrouded in dust
now I mentioned that the key thing about
the Martian atmosphere is that it used
to be a lot thicker and we know this by
studying the isotopes in the atmosphere
as an example consider nitrogen which is
the main gas that makes up most of our
atmosphere most nitrogen on earth on
Mars and in the universe is nitrogen 14
but some of it is a heavier isotope
called nitrogen 15 and when a planet
loses atmosphere it preferentially loses
the lighter isotope because the lighter
isotope floats higher up into the
atmosphere and is more vulnerable to
escape and on Mars we find that the
nitrogen 15 to nitrogen-14 ratio is 70%
greater than on earth indicating that
the planet has lost most of it
here in fact scientists estimate that
the clients probably lost over 99% of
its original atmosphere and of course
that's very important because if that
atmosphere contained gases like carbon
dioxide and water vapor could have
warmed the planet to above the freezing
point so the question is why did Mars
lose its atmosphere we don't know of any
other planet that has suffered such a
catastrophe that has lost its atmosphere
and of course the loss of an atmosphere
would have caused Mars to cool
dramatically well there are three
reasons that Mars lost its atmosphere
the root cause is that the planet was
born too small thanks to Jupiter during
the first eight hundred million years of
the solar system's life all the planets
were being pounded into by asteroids and
comets and in the case of the earth and
that could have the next slide a very
large collision gave rise to the moon
the a large objects smashed into the
earth cast up debris that took debris
then conglomerated into the moon but the
earth is a bigger planet it was able to
hold on to its atmosphere Mars with a
weaker gravitational pull was vulnerable
because the when a big impact came in it
would splatter air into space so we
think that's one way that Mars lost its
atmosphere another culprit was the Sun
the Sun emits a stream of charged
particles called the solar wind forever
the next slide we'll see a wonderful
image of the Sun this this solar wind
tries to tear away the air of an
atmosphere now the earth protects itself
because it's got a magnetic field the
magnetic field shields us atmosphere
from from the solar wind Mars we now
know when it was young also had a
magnetic field this is one of the
surprising discoveries from the Mars
Global Surveyor spacecraft which went
into orbit around Mars in 1997
unfortunately Mars lost its atmosphere
or excuse me lost its magnetic field
when the planet was young again because
the planet was born so small and at that
point not only could the impact drive
away the air but so could the solar wind
so there's an irony here the Sun the
same Sun that was trying to warm up Mars
was also tearing away the very air that
Mars needed to retain that warmth and
then the third reason that Mars lost
atmosphere is because it lost the source
of its air and what was the source of
the Martian air well we find the answer
that when we look to the third great
element of Mars fire if I could have
next slide the Martian volcanoes are the
greatest volcanoes in the solar system
pack of the next slide it shows Olympus
Mons the tallest volcano tallest
mountain in the entire solar system the
next slide shows another view of Olympus
Mons this this mountain is over twice as
tall is Mount Everest the next slide
shows the Tharsis region left of center
you see the thought of the own the great
Olympus Mons and then at the bottom you
see a diagonal column of three other
Martian volcanoes all taller than Mount
Everest and the next slide shows the
topographic map of this region of Mars
if we could have the next slide you'll
see the topography of this region on
Mars the red region again is the Tharsis
region and those white Peaks are all
volcanoes taller than Mount Everest and
again you see the the the canyons of
Mars you see when the Tharsis plateau
uplifted or rose on Mars it cracked the
planet's crust and created those huge
canyons which you see colored green and
blue they're running through eastern
Persis and the next slide shows the
canyons of Valles Marineris these
canyons are by far the greatest in the
solar system they could stretch all the
way from Cleveland to San Francisco the
next slide shows a closer view if you
look carefully at the top you'll see
enormous landslides that have further
widened these canyons and the next slide
shows a still closer view it says far as
six miles down in some of these canyons
now notice that while these canyons are
far greater than the Grand Canyon in
Arizona they also have a different cause
the Grand Canyon was formed by water but
the great canyons of Mars were formed by
fire by the uplift of the Tharsis
volcanic plateau and volcanoes are
important not only because they emit
lava most of the Martian surface is
covered with volcanic rock but also
because they emit gases carbon dioxide
water vapor nitrogen and the first two
of those are potent greenhouse gases
that warm up a planet
unfortunately because Mars was born so
small the plants interior cooled faster
in the same way that for example if you
take out a roll
from the oven at the same time there's a
loaf of bread the rolls gonna cool off
faster and well as the planets interior
cooled the volcanoes began to shut off
and that Mars lost a source of its
atmosphere and we see strong evidence
that Mars lost its atmosphere when we
look at the oldest terrain on Mars and
we study the evolution of the fourth and
final element shown in the next slide
namely water water is absolutely vital
for life here on earth life is thought
to have arisen in liquid water and we
still carry this heritage with us today
most of us are over 50% liquid water the
younger you are on the slimmer you are
the more made of water you are a newborn
baby can be as much as 80% liquid water
water is an excellent solvent can
support lots of chemical reactions it
also has a very nice property that it
freezes from the top down so for example
the planet gets somewhat cold a lake or
an ocean the top may freeze but the
bottom stays liquid and the creatures
any creatures struggling to arise there
also remain bathed in liquid water is
actually a very common thing in the
universe it's simply h2o hydrogen and
oxygen the two most common reactive
elements in the universe the hydrogen
was made in the Big Bang some 14 billion
years ago and the oxygen was made in in
massive stars that later exploded and
cast their debris into space so when you
drink a glass of water you actually
drinking part of the Big Bang and part
of the ash of ancient stars and water is
very common in the universe and the next
slide shows a comet comets contain water
ice we have the next slide you'll see a
comet what comets contain water ice the
rings of Saturn have water ice Pluto's
about half water ice so water ice is
really very common the thing that makes
the earth so special is that it's warm
enough to have water in liquid form and
it's water in liquid form that life
needs now what about water on Mars well
we know that even today even in the very
terrible climate that Mars has today
it's got water in frozen form remember
the Viking 2 lander landed farthest
north of any spacecraft on Mars at the
48 degrees north latitude same latitude
as Seattle and the next slide shows the
scene as winter was approaching the
Viking 2 landing site and you see the
water-ice there on the surface there's
water ice at the north polar cap shown
in the next slide and in the next slide
we have a south polar cap which probably
also contains water ice and there's also
water ice beneath the surface by Kevin
the next slide you'll see the Odyssey
ice map this ice map was made by the
Odyssey spacecraft which is the one I
showed blasting off at the start of this
talk this is a orientation as before
north is up South is down zero longitude
at center but this is not a topographic
map that shows where the ice is beneath
the surface and the deep blue indicates
where the water ice is most abundant
beneath the surface at the high
latitudes of the far north and far south
so there's no question that even today
Mars has got water in the form of ice
but what about water in liquid form well
I'm going to proceed here just as I do
my book magnificent Mars I'm going to
start with the very strongest evidence
for pass flows of liquid water on Mars
and then proceed more and more
speculatively and it will be your job
not mine to determine where we ality
ends and fiction begins so with the next
slide I'll show you a very dramatic
image of a of the result of a massive
flood of liquid water on Mars North is
up South is down the flood waters were
racing from Southeast to Northwest and
they sculpted out these teardrop shaped
islands and grooves in the Martian
terrain there's no question among
scientists that this was the work of
massive flows of liquid water on Mars
far greater than any floods known here
on earth however simply because they
were so dramatic simply because there
was so much water involved even in the
present frigid climate it would have
taken weeks for it all to freeze so
these flood channels actually don't tell
us anything about the past climate of
Mars they don't force us to the
conclusion that Mars was once warmer
instead stronger evidence for a warmer
Mars in the past come from more subtle
comes from more subtle features on the
Martian surface what looked to be dried
up riverbeds the next slide shows some
branching features that look very much
like terrestrial riverbeds there are
hundreds of these riverbeds or parent
riverbeds on Mars the next one the next
slide shows another dried-up riverbed
most of these most of these were about
to appear in the very oldest terrain of
Mars the next slide shows you at another
image of a possible ancient riverbed
now if these really were rivers they
differed however from the rivers here on
earth they tended to be shorter and they
didn't have as many tributaries so
suggesting to many scientists that even
at its best Mars was always colder and
drier than the earth and most of these
riverbeds date back to some four billion
years ago so that's when this water
flowed if indeed these rivers were the
work of water but to the surprise of
most scientists just a few years ago the
Mars Global Surveyor imaged features
that indicate that water flowed quite
recently on Mars the next slide shows
some gullies that look identical the
gullies in Greenland Iceland and Canada
carved by liquid water and the next
slide shows another view of a gully
these these gullies are interesting
because they're so young you know
they're not billions of years old
they're just a few million years old so
that if this was the work of liquid
water it flowed very recently on Mars
well if you can have rivers on Mars why
not have lakes on Mars those craters
that look so hostile and so alien could
have filled with water and become lakes
the largest potential lake bed would be
in the Hellas impact Basin which you see
in the next slide this is the purple
scar that I showed you on the
topographic map it measures over a
thousand miles across and if you look
carefully in the eastern part of helis
you'll see what look like a couple
riverbeds or river valleys feeding in to
that lake the next slide shows the
Hellas topographic Hemisphere at center
the purple scar is helis and those river
valleys if that's what they are are also
purple feeding into eastern helis and
the next slide shows a close-up of those
river valleys feeding in to the possible
Hellas lake the other great impact basin
in the southern hemisphere the our gyre
region may also have been alike the next
slide shows that this this large crater
of course that Lake would have been
shallower and smaller than the helis
Lake well if you can have lakes on Mars
why not go all the way and just have an
ocean on Mars remember that started the
talk I mentioned that 3/4 of Mars drains
into the northern plains and indeed the
northern plains are where any ocean
would have accumulated I'm now going to
show you a sequence of three topographic
maps all centered on the North Pole
showing half of Mars in northern half of
Mars same
schemas before blue means low red means
high but now I'm going to fill it with
water coloured black and in this image
here you see what would happen if you
filled Mars with water five hundred
meters or five hundred yards deep it
accumulates as as shown there the next
slide shows what happens if you double
the depth to a thousand yards a thousand
meters we have the next slide there you
see the ocean expanding and then the
next slide shows what would happen if
you had a an ocean that was 1,500 yards
of 1500 meters deep if we could have the
next slide please
and this particular ocean matches fairly
well a proposed shore line that
scientists had come up with in the 1980s
for an ancient ocean on Mars and the
good news is that the Mars Global
Surveyor which is now in orbit around
Mars has found that the region of Mars
inside that proposed shoreline is
smoother than the region outside which
is what you would expect for an ocean
floor the bad news is the same
spacecraft has a very good camera on it
it is imaged that shoreline and doesn't
see any shoreline features at all so of
all the watery ideas on Mars the notion
of an ocean has caused the most
commotion and if I go over the next
slide of course the reason we care about
water on Mars is because we care about
life in the universe I don't have to
tell you all that there are zillions of
stars out there many of them surely have
planets some of them are bound to be
warm and wet like the earth because as I
put it out water a common substance in
the universe but that doesn't mean that
any of them has done what the earth has
done we know what happened on the earth
it's a warm wet planets wonderful planet
it gave rise to life but there's no
guarantee that life readily arises on
another world the nice thing about Mars
is it could tell us just how readily
life arises if Mars did go through this
warm wet phase and gave rise to life
independent of the earth then that
strongly suggests that life arises
rather easily
wherever the conditions are right and
that there are trillions of other
planets that have done exactly the same
thing which case we have lots of company
in the universe on the other hand
suppose Mars did go through this warm
wet phase and fail to give rise to any
life at all then that would suggest that
even the simplest life is so much more
complex if ikemen than the chemicals
that led to its creation that it arises
only rarely and perhaps only once in the
universe in which case we could
the only planet in the entire universe
that has life so be the either way the
results from ours has profound
implications and that's a reason why the
major reason why so much effort is being
directed toward spacecraft exploration
of Mars right now so I'd like to
conclude the talk by talking about the
the two missions at NASA is mounting
tomorrow's this month the next image
shows you where the first one has landed
this is a really dramatic two-page
spread from magnificent Mars you see
this what looks like a winding riverbed
the course is over hundreds of miles of
Martian terrain and spills into what may
have once been an ancient lake at the
far left NASA has landed in that former
like bed possible former like that now a
crater called Gusev crater that was the
landing of the Mars Spirit spacecraft on
the night of January 3rd and then on the
night of January 24th NASA is going to
be lining on the opposite side of the
planet in a region called Meridiani
Planum which is also very interesting
because it contains hematite which is a
mineral and iron ore that often forms in
hot water
so at both of these NASA landing sites
we have good evidence for the past
existence of liquid water now you may
ask me well what is the chance that this
spacecraft is going to land versus the
chance that it's going to crash and to
answer that question I would rather wait
until January 26 or thereabouts but
based based right here right now we can
say that 80% of NASA landings so far on
Mars have succeeded the Viking one
Viking two Pathfinder and spirit
spacecraft all worked and then there was
a spacecraft in 1999 that crashed the
four out of five NASA landings on Mars
have actually succeeded so I think
chances are good that the January 24th
landing is going to work by the way that
landing occurs five minutes after
midnight Eastern Time as received here
on earth but the true time is 11:55 ten
minutes earlier because remember it
takes ten minutes to to receive the
information from Mars
well these spacecrafts if they work are
going to tell us a lot more about Mars
but keep in mind that science is not
done instantly so you don't expect an
answer next week or even next month as
to exactly what these spacecraft are
going to fight it's going to take months
maybe years to analyze all the data
these spacecraft return nevertheless
based on
present knowledge by studying the four
elements of Mars earth air fire and
water were able to piece together an
approximate history of the red planet it
was born 4.6 billion years ago it was
born hot
the iron core formed very fast volcanoes
erupted and gave Mars much of its
atmosphere it's entirely possible that
as a result of that atmosphere the
result of greenhouse gases the planet
got warm enough to have liquid water on
its surface rivers may have flowed Lakes
maybe even an ocean and perhaps in some
pool of water lit by the Sun and warmed
by volcanoes the first life in the solar
system arose even before any life here
on earth if that happened then that life
could have helped the planet further
because some forms of life emit methane
which is a really potent greenhouse gas
so that could have warmed up the planet
still more unfortunately because of
Jupiter's interference Mars was born
doomed it was born too small the planet
was vulnerable to impacts from asteroids
and comets which splattered its air into
space the magnetic field which protected
the atmosphere from the solar wind died
when the planet was young and the solar
wind began to tear the way to tear away
the air and again because Mars is born
so small its interior cooled fast and
the volcanoes began to shut off and so
Mars lost the source of its air as a
result Mars lost most of its atmosphere
and the planet suffered a climate
catastrophe which had it cooled enormous
Lee the rivers that once flowed flowed
only near the warmth of volcanoes any
Lakes froze and then vanished so did a
possible ocean and when the last drop of
liquid water vanished from Mars so did
any life it was sustaining the end
result is a cold dry planets but
nevertheless preserves soaring volcanoes
immense canyons winding riverbeds and
just possibly the fossils of ancient
life Mars also holds a chilling lesson
for the current inhabitants of its lush
neighbor shown in the next slide that
good planets can go bad
although the earth presently boasts a
wealth of warmth and sunshine its
present state need not be its permanent
state
just as great nations can decline so can
great planets those who occupies such a
planet if truly possessing intelligence
will do all they can to learn about
planetary evolution and safeguard their
planet from disaster Mars didn't have
time to give rise to life sufficiently
intelligent to take action and save the
planet the earth one hopes will be more
fortunate thank you all very much would
be to pass this microphone through the
audience anyone have a question yes
scientists from Cornell yes has a theory
about a deep hot biosphere in which
organisms may survive under different or
even possibly hostile circumstances do
you feel that is relevant for life on
mobile life on Mars
yes you know one thing that we've
learned about life here on earth is that
over the last thirty years is that it
can survive much more hostile conditions
than we had thought
decades ago and and certainly that
raises the chance for life on Mars or
elsewhere in the universe because let's
face it most of the universe is by our
center it's very hostile so the more
places on earth we find they're hostile
but that nonetheless have life the
greater the chance for for their being
life on Mars or elsewhere in the
universe in terms of tommy code he's a
very interesting uh he's a very
interesting man I interviewed him for my
previous book the universe at midnight
he's come up with lots of different
ideas some of them are wonderfully right
and some of them are wonderfully wrong
he was one of the chief originators for
example the steady state theory which
holds that the the universe did not have
a Big Bang that has existed forever and
on that he was wrong although he's he's
one of the few that that would dispute
his being wrong but he was also the
first to identify the first pulsar as a
neutron star and he was absolutely right
about that that was in 1968 yeah and you
want to say something it sounds like
yes there has been a recent article in
The Times concerning um galaxies
distribution differing from what you'd
expect under conditions reflecting the
Big Bang have you seen that and could
you say anything about that um I think
what you may be talking about it's the
discovery of galaxies that look
surprisingly mature that's right yeah
this is somewhat surprising but what you
know we for many many years we've
realized that the oldest stars in the
Milky Way are really you know the Milky
Way didn't waste any time gain gain
started because the oldest stars date
back almost to the time of the Big Bang
so I've I've always felt for you know
for at least for a long time that you
know the galaxies got started right away
so I the idea that these galaxies are
surprisingly mature does not contradict
the Big Bang Theory our our belief in
the Big Bang Theory is based on you
never won the expansion of the universe
the number two of the Cosmic Microwave
Background which is the afterglow of the
Big Bang and the observation that in
ancient stars the elements created by
the Big Bang match the theory almost
perfectly so I would say it's safe to
say that over 99% of all astronomers
still subscribe to the Big Bang so I
don't I don't expect any problems with
the Big Bang question what kind of
evidence are the spacecraft looking for
you know that there would have been life
there presumably there's no oak tree
that are gonna run into you know what
what kind of analysis is going on yet be
wonderful what ran into an oak tree or a
little green man but that's not terribly
likely to happen the NASA Rovers are
actually not specifically designed to
find life so I don't think we're going
to get firm evidence from these
particular missions of past life on Mars
what they are going to be doing though
is sampling the rocks sampling minerals
trying to confirm yes there was liquid
water there as we suspect or maybe it
could go the other way maybe we're wrong
but that isn't a lake bed there they
never had liquid water so they're going
to be looking at the geological
formations they're able actually to
drill into the rocks because presumably
many of those rocks been sitting there
for you millions maybe billions of years
and the veneer that it coats them from
those dust storms may not be
representative of what's inside so they
actually there's a
rock abrasion tool acronym rat that
drills into the rocks and is able to
sample the insides of the rock so I
think what we're going to be learning
from these missions is you know booking
lots of wonderful images we've already
started to get those and we'll be
learning about the minerals and rocks
there but it's extremely unlikely
unfortunately that they're going to
stumble across you know like a fossil
that that's probably something that's
gonna have to wait for a future mission
question as far as I remember seeing
this in one of the journals there was a
picture with very small fossils that
looked like bacteria yes and there was a
big argument if these are d-square
fossils of bacteria or not and after
that it was decided that it really did
not represent past life on mouse can you
elaborate about this sure the jury is
still out on that actually that was in
1996 of that discovery was announced the
very oldest Martian meteorite the one
that's 4.5 billion years old was had
these interesting features in it that
some scientists ascribed to past life on
Mars now even at the time scientists
were very skeptical and I would say it's
safe to say that over the years since
they've become still more skeptical
nonetheless the most interesting
evidence for life in that meteorite are
these magnetite crystals that are known
on earth to be formed only by bacteria
so the thinking is that maybe Martian
bacteria formed those magnetite crystals
in that meteorite on the weak link in
that argument though is that maybe
there's some non-biological process that
forms magnetite crystals that we have
yet to discover so the jury is very much
still out it's a very it was obviously a
very interesting discovery at the time
but scientists I think it's safe to say
that scientists are still skeptical so
we don't have definitive evidence for
fossils on Mars we keep in mind keep the
perspective here it's very hard even to
find ancient fossils here on earth of
life of microbial life and it's very
hard to find old fossils on the earth
the oldest known fossils on the earth
are 3.5 billion years old so it's and
it's
to find them so you'll keep in mind that
if Mars are similar that it's going to
be hard to find a fossils of microbial
life there two other questions here's a
question do you continue with your
question that raises a question will you
recognize life if you find it yeah well
we are of course we were limited in our
search for life in the universe and that
we only got one planet to face yes and
we and we're trying to extrapolate from
this one one example you know we kind of
assume that all life needs liquid water
well maybe it does it we assume we tend
to assume that life is carbon-based
maybe it's not maybe we're not being
imaginative enough I mean nature often
is more imaginative than we cite then a
scientists are so it may be that there
is some form of life on Mars or
elsewhere in the universe that's very
different from life on Earth but you
know I think scientists we're doing the
best that we can based on our limited
example of Hira here I never think
certainly the discovery of these very
extreme creatures these creatures that
live in an area extreme environments
help us in trying to recognize life
elsewhere in the universe but yeah it's
it's it's what's going to be very
interested I my own personal guess is
that in order to find fossils of life on
Mars it would probably gonna have to
send people there I I think these
unmanned spacecraft are telling us
wonderful things about Mars giving us
you know details about the rocks the
minerals the lay of the land but I
suspect that you know sending some
geologists tomorrow's is really what
it's going to take to find fossils of
life on Mars or to somehow confirm that
there are no fossils there although
that's gonna be even harder if you think
about it question here
my question is along the line of future
exploration of Mars in today's times in
the science section they had a piece
about one of the reasons we're going to
the moon is to set up the possibility of
launching exploration to Mars from the
moon and actually using metals mined on
the moon I had always thought that it
would come from the earth and in a space
station or something in there but
anyways just to expand on what you said
before how do you foresee the
exploration of Mars what would be the
timeline will I be alive for that
well I'm terrible at predicting the
future it's so much easier to predict
the past
I mean think my guess is that if we send
people to Mars it's probably 20-30 years
away from now and you can imagine in
1949 if people had been asked well what
do you think of landing on the moon is
going to be like we probably would have
gotten most of the tails wrong so you
know anything you shouldn't take
terribly seriously anything that I say
or anyone else for that matter as to
what it's it's going to be like to send
people to the two of them tomorrow's I
mean the the possibility of putting a
base on the moon a man based on the moon
is nice because it would give us some
experience about living in you know on
another planet on another world's
surface for long periods of time and we
can launch more easily from the moon
simply because it's got less gravity so
it's easier to get off the moon that is
get off the earth but my guess you know
we we could do it if we wanted to do it
you know it's simply a matter of
spending the money and investing in the
science technology developing the
science and technology that we need so
we could do it if you know if you write
a check for a sufficiently large amount
of money we could do it in probably 10
to 20 to 30 years but of course when a
large amount of money is involved that's
going to take you know probably
leadership at the presidential level and
certainly taxpayer support because you
know you the taxpayers are or would be
paying for that mission now keep in mind
that the unmanned missions are actually
very cheap I mean these two NASA Rovers
cost only three dollars per person so
you know they're not it doesn't take a
lot of political courage to to support
unmanned exploration of Mars but to
support manned exploration of Mars is a
very expensive undertaking but it
nonetheless may happen in you know 20 30
40 years but you'll keep in mind that
when we were landing people on the moon
when people talked about the 1990s back
then you really get the sense we'd be a
lot farther along than we are and we're
not really that far along because we
don't have a base on the moon yet we
don't have people on Mars we just got a
rather worthless space station and a
space and Ageing shuttle we don't have
any bold thing that NASA has really done
since the Apollo mission other questions
you said that we have Mars rocks on
earth yes and if you don't really know
what the makeup of Mars is at this
moment how do you really know that they
come from Mars and not somewhere else
good question
you know these we know that they're
meteorites they they they have the
characteristics of meteorites but they
also have trapped gases that match
perfectly the the composition of the
Martian atmosphere as determined by the
Viking spacecraft and the Martian
answers cause very different from the
Earth's atmosphere Earth's atmosphere is
mostly nitrogen and oxygen the Martian
atmosphere is mostly carbon dioxide and
a little bit of nitrogen and argon so
it's the trapped gases in those rocks
that match Mars almost perfectly that
tells us that they're from Mars I mean
there's other ways too for example they
they're they tend to be rich in iron
which the Martian surface is but it's
really those trapped gases that clinched
the argument and and show that they are
from Mars and we have now dozens of
rocks from Mars right here on earth
which is nice because you know sending a
spacecraft to Mars to land on Mars and
to retrieve rocks is expensive the
Martian meteorites in a way give it to
give those rocks to us for free they the
bad thing is we don't know where on Mars
that came from so they're not quite as
useful as an actual return mission
because then you know we would know the
age of the territory that the the rocks
come from and the geological context
here we just sort of view
we know there's somewhere for Mars but
we don't know exactly where for Mars
about the nature of your book
fortuitously you captured these images
for us prior to some of the newer images
that are coming out are you planning to
do a second book and or another area of
space well magnificent Mars is really
sort of meant to stand as this
definitive treatment of Mars at this
time and for a long time to come I mean
I do think that these new missions that
are upcoming will be returning some
wonderful images but I think if you look
through the images in the book it's
going to be hard to beat those images we
we really designed that book to be the
most beautiful ever done on the planet
Mars something to last for a long long
time and it is quite beautiful we do
have some copies of it so you're welcome
to take a look at that please help me
thank Ken Krauss well back Nick
Mars thanks Ken cross well as author of
magnificent universe and see the Stars
his latest magnificent Mars is published
by the Free Press and imprint of Simon
and Schuster visit Simon Says dot-com
for more information